Kameron just showed you how to solve
problems based on solutions developed by
other people now this is a common
practice in web development so let's ask
Jacque and see how he approaches problem
solving in his everyday work I've got
this broccoli stuffed animal let's see
if we can get his attention so problem
solving on the web is not exactly fun
but when you run into an issue with HTML
or CSS the chances that somebody else
has run into that same issue are pretty
good especially when you're starting out
so checking sites like Stack Overflow
searching around on the web for sort of
the same type of problem you're
experiencing this doesn't fit over that
why is this shifting down below here
those sorts of things will most times
yield the answer you're looking for one
of the great things about the fact that
there are so many people doing web
development is that those people run
into the same types of problems so go
check out Stack Overflow go check out
the web you can probably find the answer
that you're looking for